your big push is that you care about men
and you don't think that men are getting
enough per say
the point yet because of feminism okay
what I wonder is when you start making
calls out like repeal the 19th women
shouldn't be allowed to vote who is that
helping young men because these young
men have women in their lives they have
mothers they have sisters they have
teachers and they turn around they don't
know how to act around women because
you're giving them license to be
misogynistic I wouldn't call it
misogynistic I say be equal well again
men do all feminism well then okay I'd
love for the feminists please apply for
the oil rigs please go do the hard jobs
in society they're open they're hiring
because I don't equate for I I don't
think men or women are equal until we do
these people work so no no listen listen
go go apply to be on the oil rigs go do
go be a plumber go be electrician go be
on the front lines of the military and
then we should have equal rights but
until feminists are willing to do that I
don't believe we should have the freedom
without the response